thank you
the season finale of Ted lasso is is
about to happen and I've heard it might
be the end end is it the end well I
don't know I mean it says it's like the
end of that three season Arc oh
interesting yeah I mean I feel like
trapping him in a dungeon with a notepad
and a pen it's a good I'm just going
dude what are you doing you can't step
away from it the characters are so
beloved and we all love it I mean I
would play her when her teeth are
falling out in a retirement home like
sitting outside it with mud splashing
her you know yeah I would I just want to
see her through yeah I love the idea
that though of almost taking a show and
doing it in different like almost how
they do it like Marvel you know what I'm
saying you'd see different characters
and different things that's a cool idea
y'all should do that elsewhere yeah yeah
no Jason with camera Jason I love it you
an American
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
y'all haven't
[Music]